MANISH BHARGAVA: Hi everybody.
I'm Manish Bhargava.
I'm Product Manager for
Internationalization and
Localization Efforts
at Google.
Today we are going to talk
about developing
for a global audience.
Before we do that, let me try to
understand this audience a
little bit more.
How many of you speak more
than one language?
Good.
Nearly 100%.
How many of you here are
Android developers?
OK.
How many of you are Google+,
Chrome web developers?
Nearly 60-40.
OK.
I'll make sure I touch
upon both areas.
How many of you have your app
or product localized in more
than one language?
Keep your hands raised
if it is in
more than five languages.
More than 10 languages.
OK, 15 languages.
20.
One, two, three, four.
30 languages.
Nobody.
Oh, there is one.
Why don't you--
you are definitely ahead
of the curve already.
Why don't I give you
an Android--
[INAUDIBLE].
Perfect.
OK.
So that's good.
I saw a number of you raise your
hands in terms of more
than 10 languages.
So let me give an overview.
So first we'll touch upon
why it makes sense to go
international.
We'll discuss the steps that you
need to go global and to
make really an awesome app
for worldwide users.
And then I will talk about some
strategy considerations,
some resources, and practical
tips that we at Google, over
time, have collected.
And that should help you in
overcoming the common pitfalls
so that you can essentially, as
you go in your effort to go
international.
So first question is why
go international?
I have users.
I have revenue.
What am I missing?
So here is a pie chart
which shows
internet users by region.
So clearly if you are developing
for just one
region, and it could be any of
the regions there, you are
getting only a piece
of the pie.
In particular, if you are
developing for North America,
you are only getting 11.4%
of internet users.
Let's look at it from
another perspective.
Internet users by language.
Again, a similar pie chart,
this time by language.
And it's the same story.
If you are just developing for a
particular language, you are
getting only a piece
of the pie.
Specifically, if you are
developing just for English,
you are getting about 1/4
of internet users.
But more importantly, you
are missing out on
75% of internet users.
That's from the user side.
What about the revenue side?
Here, I'm showing you the
revenue trend of a number of
companies, Facebook, Zynga,
Google, VMware.
And you will see a
common thread.
The red portion, which is the
international revenue as
percentage of revenue, is
increasing year over year.
So whether you are driven by a
number of internet users or
the users for your app, your
product, or if you are driven
by revenue, going
international helps your cause.
So, again, many of you mentioned
you are Android
developers.
So let me go a little bit
deeper into the Android
opportunity.
So as you heard yesterday
in the keynote speech,
[? Sunter ?]
mentioned that Android ecosystem
is growing at a
really good pace.
900 million Android
activations.
48 billion app installs.
And, again, the numbers are
growing and especially from an
emerging market perspective.
And we'll talk about that.
If you look at it from a Play
Revenue perspective as well,
look at how the US revenue has
pretty much remained constant
from a graph while other
countries, more specifically
Korea and Japan, have grown
significantly over time.
So if you are only developing
for English, you are missing
out on this huge revenue uptake
which is possible if
you are developing for these
other languages.
So here is a table which shows
the internet growth and
penetration numbers.
This is taken from Mary
Meeker's 2012
internet trends talk.
I would like you to focus
on two columns.
One is the year over
year growth.
And notice some of the
emerging markets.
The numbers are in solid
double digits.
India, 26%.
Indonesia, 58%.
Look at US, 3%.
Let's also look at the last
column, which is the
population penetration.
This is number of internet users
as percentage of total
population.
India, 11%.
Indonesia, 23%.
US, 78%.
So the message here is the
growth of internet users as it
is today is really in
emerging markets.
And what is more striking
is there is
room for growth there.
And, again, it's huge
in terms of--
look at the, basically, early
teens or late teens for most
of the emerging markets in
terms of the population
penetration, while it is more
or less saturated in some of
the developed markets.
Another point which I want to
touch upon in terms of why
internationalization makes
sense is, this is the
enterprise percentage change
in advertising spend.
Notice Europe is negative .4%.
US is 1.8%.
But the real growth is, again,
coming from Asia, Middle East,
Latin America.
So, again, if you're not
developing for these markets,
you are missing out in terms of
both from a revenue, as we
saw here, but also from
a user's perspective.
So I hope I have given you
enough evidence to show why it
makes sense.
And in today's world, developing
for global audience
is not a luxury.
But it's really necessary.
And it's a huge potential
opportunity there as well.
So the next question is
I understand that.
What do I need to do for
my app to go globally?
So one thing which I'll clear
from the very beginning is
developing for global audience
is not just getting your app
translation.
So it's much more than
You can think of going global
as a two step process.
First, internationalization.
And second, localization.
So internationalization,
i18n, i followed by 18
characters and n.
And localization, l10n,
l followed by 10
characters and n.
What is internationalization?
Internationalization is
designing and coding to enable
support for languages, region,
and cultural differences.
It includes things like
externalizing localizable
resources, presenting dates,
time, number format in a
locale relevant form, processing
user input, sorting
data, and supporting characters
in all languages,
be it double wide character in
Eastern Asian languages or
bi-directional display for
Middle Eastern Languages or
supporting diacritics for
Central European languages.
In terms of localization, it's
adapting the look and feel of
your product, of your
app, for language,
regions, and culture.
It includes translation, local
defaults, and custom features.
So the question is getting it
right, does it really matter?
So in some cases, it's
embarrassing blooper.
So for example, I'll show
an example here.
This is Google Sites, the
English version, where the
font size was S,M,L for small,
medium, and large.
Anyone here can read Arabic?
No.
OK.
So I'll try.
When it got translated,
it became
Saturday, Monday, lunch.
And part of it is, again, did
it really impact in terms of
site usage?
Not really.
But it's an embarrassing
situation where, if not done
right, it impacts in
meaningful ways.
But in some cases, it
is more important.
It affects your bottom line.
So here is another example.
This is Google Maps in Sweden.
On the right hand side, you
see the English version.
On the left hand side, you
see the Swedish version.
So after we launched directions,
get driving
directions, walking directions
globally, we saw that usage
for driving directions, walking
directions, was very
low in Sweden compared to its
neighbors and compared to
global as well.
We didn't know the
reason for that.
We looked at logs and said,
let's look at those and see
what might be going wrong.
We couldn't find anything.
We hired a local consulting firm
and said, help us figure
out way we're not getting
the usage.
And, again, we didn't
make much progress.
Anyone knows Swedish here?
Can you tell what that
word would mean?
Pretty close, yeah.
Its verbal translation is
actually instructions.
So, again, without context,
get directions and
instructions, would pretty much
be OK from a translation
perspective.
But you would not expect
somebody who's looking for
driving directions to click on
instructions to get driving
directions.
So when we corrected that,
changed that to really mean
get directions, as in driving
directions, the usage went up
and was at par with neighboring
countries as well
as from a global perspective.
So just one more point on that
front is getting it right
matters in terms of when I say
it means localization,
internationalization because
it is important for a local
user to feel that the product
that they have has been
developed for them.
It's been designed for them,
rather than feeling like it's
a US or an English only version
shipped to them with
some cosmetic changes.
So we talked about that it's a
two step process, i18n and
l10n, so internationalization
and localization.
So let's go a little deeper
into internationalization.
So first is the i18n
design principle.
Essentially, designing your
product to be language and
region independent is an
important consideration.
So I'll give you some examples
where i18 and design, when
done right from very beginning,
can help you be
successful in your international
efforts.
So here is an example.
It would be from Google+ where
it could be John Smith added
five person to his circles.
This is, again, a UI text.
What might be wrong when we take
this in other languages?
What might go wrong
in some of this?
Yes.
Good point.
Any other--
yes?
Good.
Yeah.
So the hard coded aspects.
Yes.
That makes sense too.
Yes, speak loudly.
Good.
very good point.
So pretty much all of you were
pretty close and right in all
of those respects.
So first is concatenation.
So, again, we are concatenating
strings here,
which pretty much always is
a problem because when
translator gets this and they
need to translate in certain
language, they need to change
the order of these place
holders and then it would
be difficult to do that.
Second is the plural and
gender agreement.
And again, as it was mentioned
earlier, in terms of what
happens if that number
is more than one.
In English, you could
essentially do person to
persons and that
would solve it.
But think of languages like
Arabic which has six different
plural forms.
So how do you handle that
in meaningful ways?
And, again, from a gender
agreement perspective, the
name could be female,
could be male.
How do you handle that?
And then, as was mentioned here,
sometimes these would be
hard coded strings, so
non-externalized strings
which, again, is a problem
from a different language
perspective.
So how do you solve these?
Well, one way is you
do your research.
Go on internet.
Look on Google, all the
different plural formats in
different languages.
And go ahead and create
an algorithm for that.
Rather just use a library.
So, again, there is
open source ICU.
And I'll talk a little bit
more details about the
International Conference
for Unicode.
And you could use the plural and
gender library available
there for solving this, where
you don't need to worry about
what happens in different
languages.
That will take care of that.
How many of you here are back
end engineers, people who
don't deal with UI strings?
Well, you must be thinking
when we saw the UI text
example, well, I don't have to
worry about the messy string.
So I can just zone off,
and I'll be fine.
This example is just for you.
Again, this is an old example.
But we learned a
lot from this.
This is a conceptual view of
Google video, where a user
comes in, uploads their video.
It gets stored in the servers.
It gets indexed.
And then the serving server
would essentially, users would
search for them and then will
find the right videos.
What we saw is whenever the name
of the video had strings,
which used Unicode, so non ASCII
strings, users couldn't
find those videos.
What could have gone wrong?
Or where things could
have gone wrong?
Will do.
OK.
So anyone, if you want to just
come into aisle and talk about
what might be wrong or where
things might be wrong.
Come to the aisle.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
in the database?
MANISH BHARGAVA: Good
point, yes.
So that's one example where
the database and the
persistence and the backup
might be an issue.
Actually, it was all
of the above.
Every place where it could
potentially fail, failed.
And, again, there are
the details there.
The message here is i18n
impacts the back end.
And there were some design
decisions that were made which
had English assumptions.
So I'll give you one
specific example.
Notice how the last part where
upload, it required that the
name of the video should at
least be three characters.
The reasonable assumption in
English, you won't expect the
name of the videos to be
A or something similar.
But what happens when you
have names which are
in different languages?
So the character which is
shown there, I'll try to
pronounce it, [? kal ?]
is one character which
means dog in Chinese.
And it's a very common
name of video in
terms of dog as a name.
So clearly that assumption
made it
unusable for Chinese language.
So, again, from a perspective
of if you get that from a
design perspective, if you make
right decisions, keeping
into account
internationalization, you
would be able to handle many
of these situations right.
And, again, I'm happy to talk in
details about any of those
after the talk if you
have questions.
So here's another example.
This list, names of cities,
and it's arranged in
alphabetical order.
In English, pretty
straightforward.
A, C, C, H, Z. Makes sense,
alphabetical order.
In Slovak, the Ch sound is
actually a separate character.
It's a separate letter, which
goes between H and I. So in
that case, the ordering becomes
a little different.
In Danish, the A with the ring
above it is actually a
different letter.
And, again, it denotes a long
letter and a darker A. And it
actually comes after A. So in
Danish, the alphabetical order
would be that.
So, again, going back to the
principal do you need to know?
If you use, let's say, the
ASCII sorting or Unicode
sorting, you would get it wrong,
again, because each of
the language has different
nuances in terms of how the
sorting is done.
And we are just looking at Latin
character languages.
What happens if they are non
Latin script languages,
Chinese and so on?
So, again, from a perspective
of how do you get it right,
one, you could essentially look
at it and see how the
sorting looks in different
languages and know about all
these different characters.
Or you could use the library.
And, again, in ICU there is a
library which does the sorting
right for you.
So I gave you three examples
where if you get the i18n
designs right from the very
beginning, it is useful to be
successful from an
internationalization
perspective.
Now let's look at how all of
this comes together, how you
will design your system, your
architecture so that it is
right from the very beginning.
So first aspect is if you wanted
to develop code that
works across different countries
and is effective,
make sure your common code base
is language and region
independent.
It is all Unicode and that's
where all your core, core
language independent
aspects go in.
Anything which is dependent on
language or location would
essentially be handled through
the libraries.
We looked at some of the
trickier examples earlier.
But date formatting would be
another example where you
would handle them through
the right libraries.
And then there is the aspect of
localization, externalizing
your resources, that those
could be strings.
Those could be images.
So for example, hello world
string extracted and then
translated, localized
into as many
languages that you're targeting.
And having those then
externalize and then once you
get them back, [? serving ?]
for the right locale.
That, overall, is the full
picture in terms of the i18n
summary for you in terms of
getting the architecture right
from an internationalization
perspective.
So let me introduce another
concept, the
right to left layout.
So, here, what you're looking
at is a right to left layout
in English.
Would you use this if you were
to ask to use this on
a day to day basis?
Well, you probably would be OK
using it once in awhile.
But what if there are no
alternatives, if this is the
interface that you are to
use day in and day out?
You wouldn't feel really
great about it.
The same is the feeling for the
people who use right to
left languages.
So those would be Arabic,
Hebrew, Persian, Urdu, when
they have to use the left
to right interface.
These languages are also called
bi-directional languages.
Why bi-directional?
Because the text goes left to
right, but the numbers go--
the strings go right to left,
numbers go left to right.
So here, bi-directional layout
done right or the RTL layout
done right.
What you are typically used to
seeing in Gmail on the left,
they are on the right
hand side.
And unlike some of the examples
that we covered
earlier, here, it is
not as simple as
just using a library.
For getting your RTL layout
right, you need to spend some
engineering effort.
Think about that from a design
perspective and putting
engineering efforts to get it
right and from some testing
perspective as well.
So we talked about some
resources which are available.
Again, from getting the RTL
layout right, you need to have
some resources beyond just
getting the libraries.
And, again, I'll talk about some
of the resources there.
So why don't we look at some
of the resources that are
available to you in terms
of helping you with your
internationalization efforts?
So the URL to go to is
developers.googl
e.com/international.
And these resources--
and, again, I'll show you some
of the ones listed here.
What's good about these
resources is that these are
resources that either we have
developed or that we are
actively contributing to.
So anyways, for some reason
I can't display that.
But I'll just continue talking
based on that.
Developers.googl
e.com/international.
That's where you'll see listing
of about 18 resources,
tools that are available
to you.
Some of them, I will talk in
detail in the resource section
of the talk.
But I want to highlight a few.
So if you are using Closure or
if you're using GWT, Google
Web Toolkit, there are i18n
libraries that can help you
with internationalization
in those cases.
Similarly, as we talked about
bidirectional, and you need
much beyond support than just
using the libraries, there are
a number of tools available
here, the CSS mirroring tool,
[INAUDIBLE]
tool.
And, again, you can leverage
some of those.
One tool that I want to
emphasize is the pseudo
localization.
So that's essentially the tool
which allows you to mimic what
happens in the actual
translation in terms of text
expansion and adding diacritics,
so you would be
able to see much before actual
localization happens.
How will your UI look like or
UI layout look like when you
translate into, let's say,
German, where typical text
expansion is 30%?
Or you could use fake BiDi,
which will help you to see how
your BiDi layout
will look like.
The advantage of doing that in
the design and the coding and
the testing time is that
you save a lot of time.
Instead of having to wait until
actual translations come
in, you could essentially use
those at the design and the
testing phase itself.
So we looked at the step one,
which is internationalization,
making sure your code
base is ready.
The second step is localization,
adapting the
look and feel of your product
for the languages, regions,
and countries.
So what are the key
considerations that you need
to look at for preparing
for localization?
The first is determining your
target language set.
It seems like an easy task but
requires a little bit of
attention in meaningful ways.
So if you are driven by getting
more users, you might
say, well, I want to go in where
there are most users.
So look at internet users
and just go by that.
You might say, well, I'm
driven by revenue.
And then in that case, whichever
are the top revenue
generating countries, you
might target those.
Or you might say, well, I will
go in markets where my
competition has already gone in
so they are clearly users
and I would also like
to target them.
Or you might say, well, I would
like to go to those
markets where there are no
competitors so that you get
the first mover advantage.
So, again, there are different
strategies that you can use to
decide what are your target
languages, target countries,
target locations.
But that requires a little
bit of thought
initially as you do that.
The second is make sure your
localizable resources are
separate from your
source codes.
So they are in resource bundles
or extracted so that
they could be sent for
translation easily.
And then third is finding
a localization vendor.
In some cases you have one-stop
shops available, or
you could essentially use
vendors that specialize in
certain language pairs or
vendors who do multiple
language pairs.
Important aspect is the tool
that they use or you are
using, make sure it has usage
for tools, glossary, the
translation memory and
similar stuff.
Let's look at a case study.
Autodesk and Autocad WS is an
app available in Google Play,
available in iOS.
So this was published
in March, 2013.
And it talks about how they
tripled their users by getting
the localization right.
So there are two aspects.
Triple their users.
So their download rate went up
from 1,500 per day to about
5,000 per day within
six months.
They now have about
10 million users.
8.5 million of them do
not speak English
as their first language.
So among other things that this
case study talks about,
one important aspect they stress
is making sure your
product listing page is
localized properly.
What does that mean?
Making sure that it is
not just translated.
It is localized, made
relevant for the
market that you're targeting.
So a few special examples are,
let's say app screen shots.
So most of the time your app
screen shots have user names.
So John Smith.
But for localization purposes,
John Smith becomes Mario or
Carlos if you are going
in Spanish.
Or it becomes [? Dahl, ?]
for if you are going
in Chinese.
Similarly units, from inches
and feet it becomes meters.
From pound it become kilos--
so paying attention to the right
units that are prevalent
in that market.
If you have images, making sure
those images reflect the
actual experience
in that locale.
And, similarly, if you have
maps, a Japanese user would
relate more to a pinned location
in Tokyo rather than
in San Francisco.
So making sure you pay attention
to those minor
details, helps a lot, goes a
long way in terms of making
sure you get the right usage.
Up to this point, Android app
localization was difficult in
terms of there was no
easy way to do it.
It was a tedious process.
You actually had to extract
your strings, identify a
vendor, send to the vendor
outside, get those back, then
integrate them back, and then
put them back in Google Play.
What we launched yesterday,
and it's open for sign ups
now, is the ability to get your
app localized from play
dev console itself.
So, again, if you go to your dev
console today, you would
see something like sign up to
try the service where you
could essentially sign up now
and then, I think next week,
the apps will be whitelisted
and you can go
through this process.
The good part is now
it is streamlined.
It is right from the
dev console.
You can choose the
right languages.
You can choose the vendors
and do it from there.
So, again, you can find more
details at developer.google
.com/international, the
Android section.
And, again, the URL
is right there.
I would encourage
you to try this.
Let's talk a little bit about
the localization resources.
Again, the URL.
Again, if you don't remember
anything from this talk,
remember developers.googl
e.com/international.
Right there you will see
the translation tools
listed there as well.
So first is Google Translation
Toolkit.
It's a CAD tool available
for free.
You can get your docs, your
strings translated.
All of Google's localization
is done through Google
transition tool kit.
If you have YouTube videos and
you would like to get to the
captions translated,
again, that's the
tool for doing that.
The other tools which are
available is machine
translation.
And, again,
translate.google.com.
It sells millions of
translations every day.
There was a talk yesterday on
using the translate API for
going global as well.
And, again, if you have missed,
you can essentially
see that on YouTube.
If you have a website, there is
this website element, which
you could install.
It's a JavaScript, three lines
of JavaScript which you put on
your website.
And it essentially shows the
your website in the target
language based on when
user comes in.
So essentially it detects the
language and shows the page in
that language.
What is cool about this
is there is a
customized element to it.
It is not just machine
translation.
You could invite a family, you
could invite friends to go in
there and customize the page,
make changes and those will,
on the fly, be live as well.
Similarly, if you are an
advertiser and you want to
take your ads localized into
different markets, you could
essentially go to global
advertiser localization guide
and you can see more details
there in terms
of how to do that.
And we already talked about
getting your apps localized.
So now let me talk a little bit
about some of the strategy
considerations, resources,
and practical tips.
So first important consideration
is when and
where to launch.
Where should you go launch
your product, your app?
Important thing to note is
launching in a language is not
the same as launching
in a country.
So, for example, if you're
targeting Spanish, it is
whether you are targeting
Spanish as in Spain or you're
targeting Spanish as
in Latin America.
So es-419, which is the
abstraction for
all of Latin America.
Or you might be targeting
specific countries within
Latin America.
So es, as in for Mexico.
Or you might be targeting
Spanish users in US.
So es, US.
And, again, what you are seeing
there, es, es, es-419,
and all of those, those
are locales.
So, essentially, it's a
combination of a language and
country and that uniquely
defines
where you are targeting.
Then another consideration
here is there are these
multi-language countries.
For example, Canada,
Switzerland, Belgium.
So let's say if you're targeting
Canada, do you
develop in English, your
app for English?
Do you develop for French?
Or do you develop for both?
So, again, those are kind of
considerations that you need
to look into.
Another set of considerations
are law and the policy in
those markets.
So for example, there are
location based services are
tricky in certain countries.
EU has a high sensitivity
to privacy.
So you need to take
that into account.
Thailand has strict
lese majeste laws.
So if you have user generated
content, it becomes tricky in
that respect.
And, again, there's some
censorship regimes in terms of
China and Iran, great
firewall of China.
So if you're targeting these
markets, how do you handle
these scenarios?
There are some examples of if
you need data to be localized
in those markets, how
do you provide that
in meaningful ways?
So for example, if you have
you're showing the weather in
Nairobi, Kenya, you need
business deals to get those
feeds in meaningful ways.
If you're showing the cricket
scores on the news page in
India, again, you need
feeds to for you
to show all of those.
So now let's talk a little
bit about the resources.
So first is the International
Components for Unicode.
So I talked about using
the libraries.
It provides you the libraries
for handling time zones,
currencies, date formats,
and so on.
It's available in
Java, C, C++.
It's open sourced.
It's been ported to Python.
And, again, a number of
products, a number of
companies are using
this today.
Another important resource
is input tools.
Research has clearly shown that
users are more likely to
use your app, your product,
if they can input
in their own language.
That's where Google input
tools comes in.
It's a collection of tools that
provide users the ability
to input irrespective of which
language they use,
irrespective of which
form factor, which
device, they're using.
The tools that are offered in
this are transliteration,
virtual keyboard, implemented
editors, speech, and writing.
And, again, they are available
irrespective of where you are.
If you are using Windows PC,
there's a Windows client.
If you're using tablet or
mobile, you can get for
Android devices from
Google Play store.
If you're on the web, it's
already integrated in common
Google products.
So if you're using Gmail,
Search, Docs, Translate, all
of them are already there.
And there's a Chrome extension
which allows you to integrate
that in your own product
and service.
So let me quickly show
you a video for that.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
-Hi.
I'm [INAUDIBLE].
I'm a product manager
here at Google.
And I'd like to talk to you
about Google's Input Tools
Chrome extension.
With the Google Input Tools
Chrome extension, you can use
all of Google's great input
technologies, not just on
Google products, but anywhere
you can input text on the web.
To use the extension, first go
to google.com/inputtools.
Click Try It Out and Install
Chrome extension.
Alternatively, you can just
search the Chrome Web Store
directly for Google
Input Tools.
Click Add it to Chrome.
And once the Chrome extension's
installed, you'll
see the icon up here
on your Chrome bar.
Go ahead and click on it and
click on Extension Options to
select which languages and
tools you want to use.
As you can see, we support
over 70 languages.
And many languages support
multiple input tools.
I'll select Chinese Pinyin and
French virtual keyboard, and
Hindi transliteration.
Now that I've selected which
languages and input tools I
want to use, I can use
it on any web page.
For example, on Google+, I can
use Chinese Pinyin to type
easily in Chinese.
But it's not just
Google tools.
You can also use it anywhere
else on the web.
So for example, I can use Hindi
transliteration here on
the Hindi version
of Wikipedia.
We hope you find the Google
Input tools Chrome extension
to be as fun and easy
to use as we do.
[END VIDEO PLAYBACK]
MANISH BHARGAVA: A few other
resource to talk about.
[? Lib ?]
Phone Number Library.
It essentially helps you to
handle all international phone
numbers it encapsulates all the
intricacies in terms of
area codes, country codes,
and works for all
regions of the world.
It is useful for formatting,
storing, validating
international phone numbers.
And, again, used not only by
Google products but a lot of
other companies as well.
The lib address input,
very similar.
It handles the international
address format.
It's useful for the layout and
validations for all regions.
Fonts, what you're looking at
is let's say a page doesn't
have the right text to display
the page, in that case you'll
see tofu, those squares
on the page.
One aim that we are aiming for
is to remove all the tofus
from the web.
One step for doing that is
essentially creating a font
that can handle all characters
in Unicode
irrespective of the language.
And we're calling the
Pan-Unicode font Noto, so
short form for no tofu.
This will be available.
So the fonts are free for use,
for everyone to use.
They will be available from
code.google.com/pnoto.
That's where you will
find the font.
And it's available under
the Apache license 2.2.
Another useful tool
is the [? S ?]
[? Fontly ?]
library.
It's a C++ and Java library
which helps you in creating,
using, and editing
[? s fontly ?] container based
fonts, so for example, the open
type or the TrueType.
It is used, for example, by
the Google cloud print for
subsetting the fonts
for PDF printing.
So we have touched upon
the various steps
that you need to have.
We have talked about why
internationalization makes sense.
What I want to do next, logical
question is I have now
a localized app.
But how will I find the
global customers?
Or how will the global
customers find me?
So important steps in that
respect is I'm giving you some
tips in terms of getting your,
marketing your, app in the
marketplace in meaningful
ways.
So first is localize your
marketplace metadata.
That, by itself, making sure
your text, you title, your
short description, long
descriptions are localized.
That by itself will make sure
your app ranking goes up
significantly.
Maximize your search
potential.
So know which are
key, key words.
Include them in your short
description title, long
descriptions.
Why?
Because, again, search accounts
for 2/3 of the total
all installs.
More than half of all Google
Play users look for apps on a
weekly basis.
And more than six million unique
phrases are searched on
a daily basis.
Sometimes some developers have
asked, well, can I just do a
month of promotion and marketing
and will I be fine?
Not really.
Investing long term is the
right way to go from a
globalization efforts
perspective.
And as we saw in the case study
on Autodesk, localizing
app screenshots, reflecting the
actual user experience in
the locale is very important.
One, from getting more installs,
but more importantly
for minimizing your number
of uninstalls.
And that, again, is
a key factor in
terms of your app ranking.
So just to summarize, we've
talked about a number of
things here.
So if you forget most of this
stuff or you don't remember
stuff, remember a few things.
One, it makes sense to
go international.
Two, it is really simple
to get started.
Just remove your hard
coded stings.
Externalize them.
Use a few libraries.
Get your family and friends
to help you to
localize in one language.
And that would be a good
starting point.
And remember, there are lots of
resources available to you
to help with respect
to i18n and l10n.
The URL to remember,
developers.googl
e.com/international.
Again, we would love
the feedback.
This the link to the survey.
The QR code is right
there as well.
Do we have time for
some questions?
Why don't we take a few
questions and then I'll be
available here.
Yeah, come to the aisle.
Go ahead.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
I have an app on the Android
Marketer Google Play Store
that's about 300K in size
just in English.
Each language I localize it
to adds another 50 or 60K.
If I cover efigs I've doubled
the size of the app.
Is that a problem?
I mean, am I the only person
who think that's a problem?
And is Google going to do
anything about that either by
letting the market serve up
different versions of the app
by language or adding support
for downloadable DLLs that
include the localization?
MANISH BHARGAVA: So if size
becomes an issue, one way to
handle that is, again, you can
separate them by the language
in meaningful ways.
But, yes, if you have a
localized version, that is
prioritized in terms of ranking
perspective and
overall promoting that.
So, again, getting the localized
version makes a big
difference.
AUDIENCE: So I could build
a separate APK
for each of the languages?
MANISH BHARGAVA: Yes.
AUDIENCE: Perfect.
Thank you.
MANISH BHARGAVA: Yes,
that works.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: Hi, my name is
[? Kel Hoyoshoka ?]
from Hawaii.
And first I just want to say
thank you very much for
providing a Hawaiian language
version of Google for us and
also for the Maori
from New Zealand.
The input tools, however, does
not have our Hawaiian keyboard
or our Maori keyboard.
And we've been trying to find
somebody to talk to about
adding that in for
the Unicode set?
Are you the right person
and is the right place?
MANISH BHARGAVA: Yes, so
we can talk about that.
Yes, I agree with you,
input tools doesn't
support that today.
But we can talk about that.
And what we need is,
essentially, a dedicated team
who can provide us the
meaningful inputs and it could
be incorporated.
That's how we did the Hawaiian
version, for example.
So we can talk about that.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: Hello, my name is
Sean from [INAUDIBLE]
translations.
And we own a localization
firm.
And I would like to know how
to reach out more to the
Android developers and Google
Developers so that we can
actually become a vendor for
a lot of these firms.
And also--
OK, go ahead.
MANISH BHARGAVA: So, as I said,
the initial pilot phase
launched yesterday.
The way to get yourself enrolled
is-- as we said, the
initial pilot is with
six vendors.
But we are looking to expand
and scale all of that.
So, again, GPM vendor
support is the right
mailing list to use.
And that's where you
can send a note.
And, again, we can talk
in details here.
And that's where we
can get started.
AUDIENCE: OK.
Thank you.
MANISH BHARGAVA: Yes.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
My name is Tanya from
TED conferences.
We're queuing up for an app
release that's localized.
And I have two questions.
The first is if the app is
localized in Spanish, yes, is
it offensive to release
it in Mexico?
MANISH BHARGAVA: OK,
very good question.
So there are nuances in terms
or Spanish version in Latin
America, specifically
in Mexico, versus
Spanish as in Spain.
It is not offensive.
But it is not very
user friendly.
So when somebody in Mexico looks
at Spanish as in Spain,
they can kind of
understand it.
But they do realize that
it is not something
which is made for them.
So they would be like,
yes, I can use it.
It's usable, versus
the love factor.
I just want to use it comes when
you have more localized
version. es-419, does
that for example.
AUDIENCE: Do you recommend
that we do it or don't?
MANISH BHARGAVA: The es-419,
which essentially does it for
all of Latin American, unless
you are very specifically
targeting Mexico then you
can explore the es's
in Mexico as well.
AUDIENCE: OK.
And then the second question,
all about offending people, is
that in the app you
can kind of browse
content through tags.
And tags are not translated
because it's dynamic.
So even though the UI and
everything is localized, the
content translation, everything
is localized.
The only thing that
isn't are tags.
Is it better to just leave it in
English or is it better to
remove it as a feature?
MANISH BHARGAVA: I think as a
good starting point, leaving
them in English is a good
starting point.
And, again, we can talk about
how you can handle the dynamic
aspects of those So, again,
I'll be available here.
So just in the interest
of time, I know
this is lunch time.
So thank you everyone
for coming.
Read the sessions and
enjoy the lunch.
I'll be here available.
If you have further questions,
I can answer those.